this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history
and today as a lot of you guys asked for
it he's going to be breaking down the
wild west weaponry of rockstar's red
dead redemption 2.
where it falls down is the cocking and
it appears
that arthur is cocking it one-handed
which is i think
impossible if there are any other games
guns or mechanics that you guys want to
see jonathan break down
do let us know in the comments section
down below make sure to subscribe for
more videos exactly like this
and if you want to help the royal armies
museum and continue to support
jonathan's work
then please check out the links in the
description of this video alright
over to jonathan
the most cowboy gun ever i think the uh
single action army cult we have a nice
first generation
1870s vintage example and the um
the red dead 2 representation is really
good and
as we saw in the clip you can clean the
guns which i thought was a really nice
touch
maintaining your firearms was an
important thing to do and it's rare to
see it done
in the game so that's really cool
although of course a simple white with
an oily rag is not usually enough to
clean up
uh rust like that the way it functions
again pretty spot on the first person
view
pretty pretty good it's a little weird
how
he hangs on the on the hammer so that
when he pulls the trigger the hammer
flies forward out from under his thumb
almost
no reason why that wouldn't work but not
really good practice because if you
slow down the hammer there's a small
chance that the the round might not go
off
generally the rate of fire is what you'd
expect from a single action
gun i.e [ __ ] it fire it
fire you can't pull through on the
trigger to fire a shot
okay paul's there the next handgun that
we see
is another cult cult 1892 a
significant advancement over the 1873
single action army the main change being
to adopt
double action operation what we see in
the gameplay
where the player is pulling through on
the trigger i'll just do that
uh once up with this coxswain fires it
with one shot
the trigger's a lot heavier in double
action mode which causes the front sight
to move whereas single action fire
moves around a lot less it's more
accurate it's
more dependable um what we see in the
gameplay is
probably not enough shot dispersion and
in terms of balancing the guns for
gameplay
it seems like they could have balanced
better like if you lock
lock the player into firing double
action this should be fast but
inaccurate
this should be slow and slow to reload
but more accurate you pay your money
take your choice
okay cause the the remember rightly the
volcanic pistol was in both
red dead games but it looks the part it
looks victorian
the problem with it is less anachronism
because it would have been around at
that time you could have found one
and more the way the gun is depicted so
the loading is
well depicted slide this all the way up
and turn this out of the way
and you drop your rounds in there where
it falls down
is the cocking to actually [ __ ] this
thing you need two hands you've got to
hold the
actual weapon and then you've got to
apply a lot of bullets
to get the elevator to run to raise and
the bolt to come back and [ __ ] the
hammer
it is not as depicted in the game and it
appears
that um arthur is cocking it one-handed
which is
i think impossible this thing fires like
a hand cannon in the game
lots of visible recoil flash smoke and
it has
as much stopping power as a 45 or
something in reality the 41.41
inch diameter bullet certainly going to
kill someone at close range
but it doesn't wouldn't work
okay of course ah the broom handle
mauser
uh it is a classic period correct for
well period correct
itch but 1896 uh right at the end of the
victorian period so it became it really
became
widely used and known in the 1910s
the way the gun's depicted in the game
is is good it's one of the better
depictions i've seen of
the broom handling mauser and we see it
loaded realistically as well
um 10 rounds stripper clips lock the
bolt open
push them in it's not normally done the
way it's shown on screen but that no
reason why that wouldn't be effective
pull the clip out bolt goes forward and
you're ready to carry on shooting
as someone who i didn't write the book
on these but i wrote a book on these
i've got to get back into red dead too i
think
and have a go in first person with this
this is the henry rifle the predecessor
to the
winchester first available in 1860 so
well before the period of red dead 2.
the main difference as we see from the
reload animation is the
volcanic style reloading so you pivot
the front of the magazine around the
barrel
you drop the cartridges down the tube
ideally not vertically because
it is very possible for them to set each
other off as one slams into the one
they've already dropped in
and that would blow the gun up which is
not good the capacity of the tube was 15
rounds
this has six things you can get 16 in a
henry rifle by loading either one round
or the or the full
compliment cycling around into the
chamber and then topping it off by one
round
common mistake video games make is
looking at the
plus one capacity which is where you do
that and get plus one in the chamber
and applying it to the gun when it
starts out
okay you might have popped it off but
even when you reload you end up with the
full
possible compliment in this negative 16
rounds doesn't really matter
but it's a detail that you might notice
a leap ahead in 1860 a bit old-fashioned
by the uh by this time
okay pause another iconic old west
weapon
this is the 66 winchester another
upgrade from the henry other than the
much improved reloading system
with the king's gate was the furniture
you've actually got a wooden forend
which
means you don't have to burn your
fingers depicted really well i think in
the game
you can obviously just customize at the
gun shop
and replace you can sort of turn it into
pretty much in 1873
by swapping out the brass brain for an
iron frame
and this is one you couldn't have done
red dead 2 without it's just too
famous
[Music]
the remington rolling block rifle as
depicted in the game
as a um scoped sniper's rifle
effectively the way the reloads are
depicted is good
it's a little cheated i think um correct
me if i'm wrong
but now that i'm seeing it in first
person you can't just
bring back the whole breech block and
hammer at the same time
you have to [ __ ] the gun bum back the
breach
cartridge into the breach and then close
the bridge
and then find a shot whereas what
appears to happen in the game
you just somehow pull the whole thing
back in in a wanner as we say in the uk
so that's that's not quite correct
otherwise though it looks good it has
the
sort of meaty report and hit effects if
you like of
a big powerful rifle as it should
i'll pause there the this is an
interesting
gun to include and i think a a good gun
to have included in
red dead too as the name in the game
implies the varmint rifle
is very much a farm ranch tool
what you probably wouldn't do with it is
defend anything with it it's
chambered in a series of 22 calibers all
of which are very small to the damage
each shop is going to cause is going to
be less
the way that's depicted in the game is
fine people
people take multiple hits before they go
down problem from my
perspective is there are plenty of other
much more powerful weapons in the game
where the same thing happens
i'd have preferred more of a gap between
something in 22
and something in say 45 in terms of the
visible effects of damage
of course the crag the craig jorgensen
or jorgensen
a scandinavian design that was adopted
by
the us army it's depicted pretty well
rockstar generally do their homework on
firearms and the crag is no exception
this is
pretty close to well certainly the the
gunsmith's
catalog shows the norwegian original
configuration and the bolt is
works as as advertised as depicted when
you want to reload
you flick open the magazine and you drop
the cartridges in and the way it's
depicted is
probably how you do it a bit a bit like
other weapons in in
the red dead games the enemies are a bit
bullet spongy
a center mass shot from something like
this you're not getting up again
as they do tend to in the game
pause there it's just occurred to me
that i don't think i've ever seen a pump
action shotgun
in a western and in fairness this is
another very
late in the day weapon for the classic
western
1897 we see the winchester 1897.
probably well one of the first really
capable
12 gauge pump action shotguns tube
magazine
with and these a couple of things stick
out when you uh when you open the action
on this that
aren't necessarily there on modern pump
actions and that's depicted correctly in
the game
gives you gives you some interesting
options in uh in a western game to be
able to essentially
tool around like a like an action hero
the
effects that are shown are pretty
realistic for a game we're used to
seeing lots of
widespread shots devastating a very
close range
tickles the enemy at distance whereas
this thing is
shown to have some pretty effective
range and a much tighter
pattern of shot that just causes a lot
of damage
okay pause the browning auto 5
or a5 shotgun the grip doesn't move it
is a self-loading
shotgun as it's shown to be in the game
this is a classic case of
how can we have a period set game that
still has some cool modern weapons in it
turns out the auto 5 shotgun was first
invented in 1898
just squeaks into uh red dead
redemption's 1899
frame but so many of what we now think
of as uh modern firearms
are around by 1899. it's 12-gauge
shotgun that fires as fast as you can
pull the trigger
and another pretty well represented
model in the game
and first-person view looks looks right
to me as well
the remington model 1889 one of many
double-barreled what we call hammer guns
because they have hammers on them
external hammers rather than internal
firing mechanisms now this is one that
we haven't got
what i've grabbed instead a british
equivalent
that's quite highly decorated the
hammers
are interesting from from a nerdy gun
gamer point of view
because of the reloads so we saw this
very
graphically with the with the dual wield
of
the sort of sawn off version of this all
that where we're somehow able to
to not only open the gun and load both
chambers with
the other hand full which is difficult
enough
very doomed to fudge the reload where
the cartridge is coming from
we've also got the hammers to worry
about now those do not [ __ ] themselves
you have to open it up remove the
empties if it doesn't have an ejector
thumb in two new cartridges close it up
cut one barrel [ __ ] the other barrel and
then you're ready to
to proceed they've cheated it in the
game i think just out of
uh frustration factor so it's another
iconic old west type of firearm the fact
that they've gone with the remington is
just the choice they've made
probably because it looks really cool
thanks everyone for watching um some
really interesting guns in
red dead 2 really well depicted if you'd
like to
make a donation to the museum you can
follow the link in the description
we've even got a membership program if
you'd like to
pay a bit more and do that no pressure
though we appreciate you watching and
see you next time
[Music]
you